good
[Music
] good morning I am héctor mejía with
your brief informative for today wednesday
march 17 if you need to obtain a
coronavirus detection test
there will be several places available this
week we start with the
health district of southern nevada which is
open  Monday through Friday the
xian foster building located in the bid has
appointments available this week and also
the fire department if possible
and is offering tests today for more
information on hours and locations you
can check the page and insead
dotcom diagonal in Spanish
at  other news the
employment department known as 'el says
a delay in payments is expected after
an extension in unemployment benefits
under the federal bailout plan
signed last week these
benefits will be extended until
September payments will be delayed
a week  does what the department
requests the programming guide for the
system will continue with  the help of an
additional 300 dollars per week
until September of this
year many are having a hard time putting food
on the table in times of pandemic for
this reason clark county together with the
culinary academy are organizing a
ride trough food delivery today and tomorrow  today it
will be at the cambridge recreation center
from 10 in the morning to noon
now we start with the weather forecast
today that impact exists on
saint patrick's day we will have a sunny day
with temperatures in the 60s for today we
say goodbye to the wind and cold since
temperatures will go up to 70 for
the rest of the week have a nice day
I'm héctor mejía and this was about
disney news in spanish
[Music]